I couldn't think of a better way
to end my visit than performing
at Sydney's historic State Theatre.
I brought along three of my good friends
from the The Basic Cable Band.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Plus, I was joined by three
hilarious Australian comedians.
Steen Raskopoulos, Becky
Lucas, and Rhys Nicholson.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
Hello Australia!
(crowd cheering)
You guys, you're so cheerful.
This guy was talking to me he was like,
yeah, we got no ozone
layer, (crowd laughing)
we got no ozone layer!
And, I thought why is he saying
it like, it's my birthday?
(crowd laughing)
What's your favorite cereal?
What's the cereal you love?
(man shouting from crowd)
Wait what?
This guy out there yelled like
a caveman who'd been shot.
(crowd laughing)
Duh, bah!
Sir, just that guys who's
been yelling, what is it?
[Man In Crowd] Weet-Bix!
(crowd cheering and clapping)
You, come here!
For (bleep) sake.
(crowd cheering and laughing)
What is it again?
Just you, no one else.
Weet-Bix.
And what's it made of?
Wheat.
(crowd laughing and clapping)
Should've gone to Melbourne.
(crowd laughing)
You guys are just screwing
with the rest of the Earth.
(crowd laughing)
I'll 'ave a jubney bubney, what's that?
Cinnamon cracker.
Wait, well why didn't
you say cinnamon cracker?
(laughing evilly)
(crowd laughing)
We got 'cha, good on ya.
Now to be fair, each song
gets an even chance here.
In light blue, You Shook Me
All Night Long by aca-daca.
And then in yellow,
Skippy the Bush Kangaroo.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Why do you want Skippy the Bush Kangaroo?
(crowd laughing)
[Audience Members] Skippy, Skippy!
Skippy, Skippy!
(band plays "You Shook Me
All Night Long" by AC/DC)
♪ She was a fast machine ♪
♪ She kept her motor clean ♪
♪ She was the best damn
woman I had ever seen ♪
♪ 'Cause the walls start shaking ♪
♪ The earth was quaking ♪
♪ My mind was aching ♪
♪ And we were making it and you ♪
Anyone here with the guts to come up here
and try and sing like that?
♪ I said you ♪
♪ Shook me all night long ♪
(crowd cheering)
No!
[Man In Crowd] Yeah!
Who the (bleep) is that guy?
(crowd laughing)
♪ Skippy, Skippy ♪
♪ Skippy (mumbles) true ♪
(laughing)
Wait a minute, you have
the lyrics right here.
(crowd laughing)
They're right here and you're like,
Skippy, Skippy, va va va va.
(crowd laughing)
That's how Americans
sing The National Anthem.
(crowd laughing)
Skippy!
Skippy oi oi!
Oi Skippy (crowd laughing)
Skippy Bush Kangaroo!
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Thank you Sydney!
Thank you Australia!
(crowd cheering and clapping)